there are an enormous number of aspects
of modernist culture the culture of the
last hundred years or so which simulates
schizophrenia well it's my pleasure to
welcome dr. Iain McGilchrist
psychiatrist and author of the master
and his emissary the divided brain in
the making of the Western world
here to AEI dr. McGilchrist holds
multiple fellowships at Oxford
University the Royal College of
Psychiatrists and the Royal Society of
Arts so welcoming in it's good to have
you thank you very much Ben so I hear
from others that one question authors
don't usually get asked when they come
on to a program like this is what's your
book about so why don't you start there
and and give us a little bit of what
your book is about but it's about the
vexed topic of the difference between
the brain hemispheres a topic that has
become rather toxic topic because of its
exploitation by media people and pop
psychology hmm and it started with
things that we learnt well he took off
let me say because we learnt differences
about the brain hemispheres in the 19th
century but it really took off after the
first split brain operations in Caltech
in the 1960s where the brain was divided
this was for treatment of intractable
epilepsy and it gave people an insight
into what the brains the two halves of
the brain might do that were different
and out of that came a number of ideas
that eventually were proved to be wrong
they were for example that the left
hemisphere does language and reason and
the right hemisphere does emotion and
pictures and with further research it
was found that in fact both hemispheres
were involved with everything but in a
that does a bit that we didn't notice
was that they involved consistently in
two entirely different ways
and the subject would fall into
disrepute because we were only asking
the machine question what does it do and
we're finding that they both involved in
doing everything but the question the
more human question and after all the
brain is part of a person in what way do
they do was not being asked but if you
ask that question you get a fascinating
series of answers and my book is really
expounding what those differences are
between the two brain hemispheres and
what inference that might have on on the
history of culture including and
specifically our own culture now you
talk about the right hemisphere of the
brain as being the master yes and you
talk about the left hemisphere as being
the emissary yes tell us what you mean
by that well the image comes from a
story of a wise spiritual master who
looked after a community so well that it
flourished and grew and after a while he
discovered that he not only couldn't
look after everything that was needed by
this these people this community but
that importantly he couldn't be involved
in certain things if he was to maintain
his overview so he delegated that job of
going about and doing certain quite
specific detailed administrative tasks
to his brightest and best servant the
trouble with this guy was that he was
bright but not bright enough to know
what it was he didn't know and so he
thought I know everything what does a
master know he doesn't know anything
he's sitting back there smiling seraphic
aliyah back it was a base he doesn't
know anything I'm the one that does all
the heavy lifting I really understand
the trouble is he didn't know what it
was he didn't know he didn't know what
it was the master knew the master knew
he needed the atmosphere of the Emmis
who didn't know he needed a master and
this bled to the collapse of the
community and and this is a parable the
parable I think applies to the
relationship between the two neuronal
systems the two hemispheres one has a
broad view
which includes the need for a detailed
view it has a global view that sees the
need for certain quite specific facts
and data the other hemisphere and this
is the left hemisphere sees only the
details but has no concept that it's
missing the big picture it thinks that
maybe you can put all these details
together and they'll compose the big
picture but actually it's not like that
we think and the left hemisphere can't
see that it could be otherwise that a
whole is simply made by putting together
the parts but actually the whole of many
things as we appreciate in living is not
the same as what you get when you take
it apart into a handful of pieces and so
you've used some interesting examples in
the past about this from the animal
kingdom yeah and and how you sort of how
the penny dropped as it were when you
started studying animal behavior and
could you talk a little bit about that
because I think that helps to explain
under the this left-right it happens to
our distinction yes well it's not just
human beings that have lateralized
brains in other words they have two
halves of the brain that are not
symmetrical by the way they're not
symmetrical in anything you can measure
anatomically or physiologically so
functionally structurally they are
different reliably so but this is not
just about humans it's not even about
Apes it's not even about mammals or
reptiles or amphibians or fish or
insects or nematode worms every existing
living thing that we know that has any
kind of neuronal structure at all has an
asymmetrical one and that leads the
question why and there is an answer to
this which gradually dawned on me which
is that it has an important evolutionary
significance that is that it solves a
conundrum how to eat and stay alive and
that doesn't sound like a conundrum to
us now but for most animals it's a
dangerous business
being focused on one thing because
you're obviously not looking at
everything else so while your folks
on catching that rabbit picking out that
seed against the background of grit you
know picking up a twig to build the nest
you've got to have very sharply focused
attention just very narrow view
attention to a detail but if that's the
only attention your pain you'll soon
become somebody else's lunch while
you're getting your own because you need
to have a sustained vigilance for
predators for conspecifics for others
that are around and for everything else
basically that is going on in the world
and when you observe animals and bird
what you find is that the left
hemisphere serves the predator instinct
in which you go for some detail and
therefore is good for manipulating the
world but it's not terribly clever it
doesn't really see the whole picture it
doesn't understand what it's doing but
it's a servant it's a very good servant
the right hemisphere meanwhile is
understanding the whole thing and saying
I see where this thing of getting my
lunch and getting that twig for this how
that fits into the hole and what I am
suggesting is that in the way in which
we now think we've got locked on to a
rather unintelligent way of thinking
that enables you to be very efficient at
grasping but not very efficient at
understanding and you think about it the
left hemisphere is the part of your
brain that controls your right hand
which is the one with which you do all
the grasping and it's it's the one that
controls the bits of language not all of
language but the bits that enable you to
say oh I've grasped lip in other words
you've got some little certain factoids
but the problem is you try to live a
wise life on the basis of putting a lot
of these together and you simply can't
you've covered pretty well for us the
scientific side of this but that's only
half of your book the second half of the
book is really devoted to an analysis
cultural analysis historical analysis
and I'd like you to unpack that a little
bit you know in terms of what your
research what you think your research
tells us about the development of the
West Western civilization the trigger
for this came from a book by a
distinguished colleague called Lewis SAS
who wrote a book called madness and
modernism and it effectively what that
book demonstrated was that there are an
enormous number of aspects of modernist
culture the culture of the last hundred
years or so
which simulates schizophrenia in other
words people who suffer from
schizophrenia describe experiences
depict phenomena that are extraordinary
like those that are in the mainstream of
modernism now that was a and and he over
500 pages he shows this time and time
again in in great detail it's very
convincing for example many of the
movements in the visual arts in the last
100 years exemplified various phenomena
of distorted vision which are found in
people with right hemisphere damage so
some of the actual movements that became
popular exemplified phenomena that until
now have been quite peculiar to people
with schizophrenia and you see this also
in for example the literature where a
deliberate effect of sense of alienation
that perhaps other people are machines
are not really living but they're almost
like sort of terrifying zombies or the
sense that you yourself are cut off and
unable to feel for anything and the
distortion of perspective the deliberate
disruption of narrative which has been
part of the way in which novels have
been written that periods during the
last hundred years and the willingness
to strip things away from context and
deliberately make them seem strange or
odd creates an effect which and is
awfully like the experiences that people
with schizophrenia describe they seem to
be experiencing something that modernist
artists writers and even philosophers
seem to be tackling which is this kind
of D vitalization this alienation this
disembodiment
and this mechanization and so forth
which comes out in the art and culture
so question is why and I this struck me
like a thunderbolt
because I've been researching at Johns
Hopkins in Baltimore on a symmetries in
the brain of people with schizophrenia
and what I had learned about as many
other things apart from the fact that
their brains are not asymmetrical in the
way that ours are is that people with
schizophrenia are awfully like people
with right hemisphere brain damaged
people with right hemisphere strokes or
tumors or injuries experience things
describe things to pick things in the
way that people with schizophrenia do
broadly I mean there are differences but
that's a very substantial similarity and
so what I took from this was that it
wasn't that we were all becoming
schizophrenic but that maybe we were not
utilizing what our right hemispheres
Teller's we were listening only to what
our left hemispheres tell us and I
looked at that for quite a long time and
saw masses of evidence that this seemed
to hold up and I then thought well if
that's the case and in the past we've
had you know different kinds of culture
there mean many movements in the history
of ideas in the West they presumably
weren't all so skewed in this way and I
looked at the ancient Greek civilization
at the Roman civilization and that our
own modern civilization starting with
the Renaissance and moving forwards
through big movements like the
Reformation the Enlightenment from
mantises and modernism and
post-modernism and to abbreviate a much
longer story and effectively what I saw
there was the same shape repeated and
that shape goes like this at the
beginning of a civilization it seems
suddenly to erupt with a great
efflorescence of ideas thoughts creative
material in in in poetry and drama
in in history-making in the writing of
myths in the exploration of the seas the
Stars the the use of mathematics even
the beginning of engineering and these
things then over time which are so
effective and so flourishing quite soon
I've repaired of usually about four or
five hundred years deteriorate in a
recognizable way the society becomes
more rigid it becomes more steeply
hierarchical it becomes more
bureaucratic it becomes more interested
in control and power than it is in
actually imagination which requires that
you make yourself vulnerable in certain
waves and it simply can't afford to do
this and the Greeks over reached
themselves with their civilization the
Romans did the same and they collapsed
now in our own case I believe that we're
following the same path that we were
very rich in creativity for a few
hundred years and that there in the last
certainly particularly the last 150
years there has been an overemphasis on
domination getting Empire first notably
the British and then more in a
commercial sense the Americans and
cultural domination in which I think a
very diminished sort of bureaucratic
necessarily so because when you've got
an empire you know what are you going to
do you're going to be emphasizing the
military and the bureaucracy and the
administrator has to be managed it has
to be managed and so management think
which to me is the death of imagination
becomes the if you like the way in which
everything is interpreted it's
interpreted as essentially knowable
quantitative objective and essentially
dead
whereas in fact everything we experience
is changing animate and multiply
connected to everything else we know so
one living animal changing pleasantly
constantly leading one beyond the
horizons of what one knows now that kind
of a world
gets eliminated in favor over dead
static contained and knowable nothing
that's where we're at
well that's a little daunting so tell me
how you see they just to build on that a
bit for the average person who's
thinking about what you're saying
what would you point to as evidence of
this over working I guess of the left
hemisphere in our in our society around
us how does it manifest itself well I
don't know what it's like in America but
if you try dealing with any
administrative body even with your bank
or the telephone company you find
yourself pushed down an algorithm that
doesn't have anything to do with your
circumstances and it's over control and
people who are not as it were trained or
educated to the point where they can
think for themselves are dealing with
this as a new situation instead they
have a repertoire of stale abstractive
situations which they are told to handle
in certain predicted ways and
unfortunately life is never like that
and almost never can be solved in that
way so I mean it's problems can't be
solved in that way so this is something
that I imagine we all have experience of
also our educational system has in my
lifetime gone from being something which
encouraged free thinking in fact the
purpose of it was to encourage people to
think differently to question the the
whatever the received thinking of the
age was and also to learn hard a lot of
the things about the past which would
help you to interpret the present and
give a context to it nowadays people are
not interested in and don't learn about
the past they're over technically
educated and under humanistically
educated they don't actually know much
about history which is after all the sum
of human experience so far they don't
then are encouraged to examine
imaginatively literature which enables
you to get into other worlds than they
than the one we now live in I mean the
whole point of Education is not to be
the worst possible thing say it must be
relevant what that means is it's got to
replicate whatever it is we're stuck in
now but the point of Education to break
out of what we're stuck in them and so
that's that that's the arrow and if you
now I mean I used to teach literature
and one of the marvelous things about it
there's the great literature is
absolutely unique impossible to re
rephrase as a bunch of ideas
it just has a powerful if effect on you
as an embodied being you know and then
now I mean I have a daughter who studied
English and I mean what she studied was
first of all very little of what I would
call the Canon which is now considered
to be somehow irrelevant but actually
without it you can't understand where we
are now if you don't understand history
you don't notice know where you are
right like trying to abstract yourself
in space and say where am i and you
delete all the all the places around you
don't know where you are or what you do
so that happen and then of course the
attitude is to be superior to the work
because you now have information that a
point of view that this poor sucker who
wrote this play or novel and the past
didn't have so we now take him off oh he
was a racist and a sexist Anna and I
whatever and we never actually make
contact with the thing as a living thing
that is speaking to us imaginatively
I mean this is terrible so I mean I
think all of us have been all of us have
you know kind of deep concerns about the
nature of public discourse today you
know the inability the lack of empathy
the lack of imagination and creativity
and problem-solving and and things like
that do you think that's a function of
this phenomenon well I think this
phenomenon if I'm right that we trained
to dis attend to things that are not
explicit and that are not in the
foreground and actually all the interest
is going on in the background the
context the implicit if that if I'm
right and we're mainly focused on
grabbing the obvious then we would be
living in a materialist society that
didn't value
spiritual things which simply can't be
measured and can't be proved it would
tend to prefer technical matters that
can be measured to those that are
creative it would tend to stultify the
intellect and I think that is what is
happening and people aren't trained to
think critically about their own
opinions so you get you know when I was
at school I was taught the purpose of an
education is to be able to give graded
consent or graded dissent to any
proposition and I believe there is
nothing so good that more and more and
more of it is just better and there is
nothing so bad the little bit of it
might not do some good and if you accept
that and I think it's hard not to
then it's the discussion has to be about
where we should position ourselves on
this continuum that is not had as a
discussion because people are polarized
the left hemisphere tends to be
extremely crude in black and white and
sets up opposition's the right
hemisphere is better at seeing that
things that look like opposites make oh
here they may actually need one another
and coexist but I'd like to say that one
of the most important things in which
our younger people can see the fruits of
this way of thinking all around us in
the what we know about the destruction
of the natural world the destruction of
species of poisoning of the seas the
deforestation of the of the earth in the
tendency to grab resources at the
expense of say whole indigenous peoples
that get wiped out and the over control
of all lives through monitoring of every
kind DNA databases CCTV cameras
monitoring your online movements and so
forth and this is has become a
totalitarian nightmare already in China
and I worry about this being exported
here there are already science that it
is actually happening it it is happening
here and but it's interesting because
it's coming through the private sector
rather than the government yeah
as can I talk about predicting yes
please ready hell yeah and do you know
about predictive no please don't
okay well you know in China they have
this Social Credit system whereby
everything you do is monitored and
evaluated and if you talk to the wrong
person or voice the wrong opinion or buy
the wrong thing in a store this counts
against you and if you get enough black
points you bad points you can't actually
get a job or or to take a loan or even
move from your town because you can't
buy a train ticket well believe it or
not in America there is a private
company called predicted him that has
developed an algorithm and these things
always starters for your own protection
you know how everything sinister it gets
in to make things safer and this one is
about how can you get safer than this
babysitting oh that really speaks to the
core because everybody wants to protect
their child so there is an algorithm it
will tell you whether a babysitter is
reliable and how does it do that it
monitors your Facebook page and your
Instagram posts and everything that they
can find out about the websites that you
visit and it looks at your face and your
facial expressions and movements and
record your opinions and it can't tell
the difference between that a funny
remark a sarcastic remark or a mark out
of context or anything else and it
creates a score a mindless score that
even the people who created it don't
know where it gets the data from and you
the victim of this don't know why you're
getting a bad score and that would
perhaps not matter very much if it only
happened if you were babysitting
but now companies are using predictive
data to hire people so if you've got
like you voiced an opinion that was
controversial you'll mark down as a
troublemaker but the society needs
people who are going to be a little bit
rebellious right right Wow
okay so let's wrap up on this question
if as you say this problem of left
hemisphere dominance has occurred in the
past why should we worry about it you
know won't it won't just correct itself
over time the way it has in the past
well the last time a civilization
collapsed in the West it took a thousand
years for one to re-emerge so that would
be concerning but not very but the thing
is that in the late Roman Empire they
were able to commit suicide as a as a
civilization but they weren't able
actually physically to destroy the means
of life but we now have accelerating
power logarithmically accelerating power
and technology is a wonderful thing if
you're wise enough to know how to use it
but every technology can be used for
good or ill and it's only a matter of
time before that immense power falls
into the hands of people whose desires
are not good not once we would
appreciate and so at the same time that
society faces the possibility of a
totalitarian regime quite quickly
amassing an enormous amount of data such
that you know it just Dwarfs anything
the Soviet system ever thought of that
can happen it can happen in the West if
people say it couldn't happen here
that's nonsense democracy is a fragile
flower and it can easily be trampled on
and you know we saw totalitarian regimes
arise in places like Germany and Italy
in the last century places with a long
civilized history so that can happen and
the other thing that I'm talking about
is which seems to me the most serious
thing of all is that I think there is
good evidence that climate change has
now got to the point where it is
irreversible and the consequences of
this mean that there will be changes in
the way in which people can inhabit
certain parts of the world in other
words the view mass migrations of
populations away from areas of drought
and famine and these will be so large
that they can't be policed or resisted
and there will be a breakdown in civil
order now if that happens if this
civilization will end
and it may be not just a matter of a
thousand years but if the planet is
properly despoiled it may be much much
longer the planet will survive people
say let's save the planet I would said
the planet is amazingly resilient the
planet has been through many many things
it's human beings that are fragile and
the planet will survive but we won't be
there to see it
then I happen to think that's a great
shame dr. Miguel Chris has been a
pleasure having you with us today thank
you very much thank you for asking me hi
everyone that's the end of our
discussion with Ian McGilchrist thanks
for watching as always let us know what
other topics you'd like a di scholars to
cover on viewpoint and to learn more
about how our brains pay attention to
the world check out the links in the
description below